did you know that two out of every three
guys is going to experience some form of
male pattern borders by the time they're
35 yeah you do look at this guy lost it
at 25. i wish keeps have been around
when i was younger when i was 25 because
advancements in science meant that there
are now treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair that you have it's too late for
me my hair's not coming back but you
don't have to be like me you can stop
your hair loss early thanks to keeps
keeps off as generic versions of the
only two fda-approved drugs for treating
hair loss so you might have tried them
before but never at a price this low
that's right if you're thinking oh simon
this is medicine it's going to be mad
expensive you couldn't be more wrong
keep start sat wait for it just 10 a
month how's it work were you done to go
to the doctor you just go online get a
quick online consult a little bit later
discreet package arrives at your door
and you can use it in the privacy of
your own home so look if you're noticing
that you're losing your hair that's not
a problem that's going to fix itself i
promise you that do something about it
for a limited time go to keeps.com
forward slash biographics or click the
link below to get 50 off your first
order and now today's video
is there such a thing as going too far
in the name of a righteous cause is
violence an acceptable answer when
confronted by a great evil these are
questions that have been hotly debated
for hundreds of years and will probably
go on being debated for hundreds more
without the being a conclusive answer
decided upon take for example the person
of john brown in the 19th century
depending on who you are the man was
either a gallon warrior martyred in a
noble cause or an insane murderer who
needed to be put down even today his
legacy continues to be debated by
historians was what he did a good thing
was he a soldier of christ or america's
first domestic terrorist well today
we're going to tell you a story and you
could decide for yourself
john brown was born on may the 9th 1800
in the farming town of torrington
connecticut his father owen had been
working for himself since he was 12
years old after his father had died in
the revolutionary war and was now a
well-respected cobbler and tanner in
addition to being a subsistence farmer
from owen and his mother ruth young john
would learn the value of a strong work
ethic and most importantly their strict
calvinist faith which taught that they
were all unworthy sinners completed the
mercy of an omnipotent loving and well
sometimes wrathful god in 1805 owen
moved his family to hudson ohio another
small town 25 miles southwest of
cleveland there he became a prosperous
businessman and became known in the
community as square owen john meanwhile
grew up briefly entertaining the idea of
becoming a minister but he ran out of
money before completing his education
went back to working in his father's
tannery business before setting out on
his own john brown even in those days
was probably not a fun person to be
around he had no hobbies was not one for
jokes or levity and acquaintances
described how his steel grey eyes his
most striking feature would seem to
glare at your very soul whenever he
looked at you what was worse he had a
truly colossal ego he truly believed
that he knew better than everyone else
around him about every subject and would
not take advice or criticism from anyone
according to one of his brothers he gave
orders like a king against which there
is no rising up
another thing that john brown inherited
from his father was his opposition to
the practice of slavery in america most
the founding fathers even the ones that
owned slaves recognized that the idea of
holding others in bondage was
incompatible with the idea of a truly
free republic as laid out in the united
states constitution fearing for the
survival of the new country however they
hadn't done anything about the practice
hoping that it would die a natural death
over time but the invention of the
cotton gin in 1793 made the production
of cotton an immensely profitable
activity in the southern states and the
big plantations required hundreds of
slaves to work the fields the economy of
the south was therefore almost entirely
dependent on slavery which helped create
a growing rift between it and the
northern states which were transitioning
away from agriculture and towards
factories and industry there had always
been opposition to what was
euphemistically referred to as the
peculiar institution particularly in the
north but abolitionism as an organized
force began in the 1830s this coincided
with a religious revival that swept
through the north known as the great
awakening evangelical ministers began to
preach fiery sermons that said slavery
was not only against the ideals laid out
in the declaration of independence but
against the laws of god almighty a
mortal sin that stained the entire
nation not just its practitioners
articulate reformers such as william
lloyd garrison published anti-slavery
newspapers and books demonizing the
practices immoral and ungodly it is
notable however at this point there was
no call for violence in order to free
the slaves abolitionists hope to end
slavery through legislative action or by
pricking the conscience of the southern
people when a slave named napturner led
violent interaction in 1831 that was
quickly put down newspapers in the north
as well as the south condemned it john
brown while personally opposed to
slavery from birth was not focused on
the institution just yet he was focused
on building his business interests and
taking very seriously god's commandments
be fruitful and multiply between his
first wife dionth who died in 1832 and
his second wife mary john had 21
children 10 of whom died before reaching
adulthood the ones who did survive were
subject to strict discipline forced to
live the same austere religious-based
lifestyle but he himself practiced
brown's businesses were rather less
successful than his efforts to populate
the earth it didn't seem to matter what
he tried tannery land speculation
selling wool all the businesses he
started failed putting him in debt and
forcing him to declare bankruptcy most
of his financial troubles were brown's
own fault he insisted that he was a
businessman without peer that he knew
what he was doing even when he didn't
and that anything that went wrong was
somebody else's fault namely people
trying to cheat him his erratic dealings
but some who knew him to question his
sanity it's not the last time that would
happen
by 1854 john brown had been chased out
of ohio pennsylvania and massachusetts
by his creditors he was living in north
alban new york a remote farming
settlement for freed slaves in the
adrian deck mountains on the shore of
lake placid which would go on to host
the winter olympics twice in the 20th
century by the way brown had become more
and more involved with the issue of
slavery in recent years he had served as
a conductor on the underground railroad
a secret network of northern
abolitionists and free blacks that
worked to spread slaves out of the south
and get them to freedom in canada beyond
the reach of slave captures and the
police who were compelled to aid them by
the terms of the fugitive slave act
passed by congress slavery was becoming
more and more of a divisive issue in the
1850s anti-slavery sentiments ran high
in the north so not because of moral
qualms about the practice as the
abolitionists proclaimed many
northerners chafed at the idea of the
slave power that is the southern states
attempting to impose their will on them
the south wielded a disproportionate
amount of power in congress thanks to
the three-fifths compromise in the
constitution which allowed southern
states to count each slave as
three-fifths of a person in the census
this awarded them more seats in the
house representatives than they would
have otherwise been entitled to since
quite obviously the slaves were
ineligible to vote these seats were
filled by pro-slavery politicians who
did everything possible to advance the
interests of the southern economy which
you'll remember by this point was
dependent on slavery and this was all at
the expense of the northern one john
brown was one of the few white men in
america who was not only an abolitionist
but who treated black people with
respect though not necessarily as his
equal not because of prejudice but
because john brown saw no one as being
his equal he was living in north elba in
order to teach the freed slaves their
how to live off their land and fend for
themselves brown hoped to eventually
create communities of freed slaves like
this all over america that was when a
letter from his sons came that would
change his life
in 1854 congress passed the kansas
nebraska act instead of a longitudinal
dividing line that split the country
into free states and slave states from
now on each new territory added to the
union would decide for itself which one
they would be ostensibly a democratic
measure the law seemed designed to cause
conflict between two sections of the
country that increasingly distrusted
each other the battle lines were drawn
in the kansas territory migrants from
northern states known as free soldiers
flooded into kansas and established
settlements like lawrence and topeka the
pro-slavery faction moved in as well
swarming across the border from
neighboring missouri knowing that they
didn't have the numbers to carry the day
the southerners resorted to cheating
taking control of the ballots by
threatening violence and casting illegal
votes because of this they elected an
overwhelmingly pro-slavery legislature
the three soldiers had rejected this
legislature and elected their own
representatives meaning the two rival
governments were now in place in kansas
both claiming to be legitimate kansas
was a powder keg ready to explode and
john brown was about to show up carrying
a flaming torch to throw
right into the middle of it brown had
received a letter from five of his sons
who had chosen to make a go of the new
frontier and wanted to know if their
father wanted to come along initially
brown declined but as he heard of the
deteriorating situation in kansas he
decided to go arriving in 1855 among the
supplies he brought with him were
weapons including rifles pistols and
several broadswords to protect
themselves from the missouri border
raphians as they were known the free
soldiers formed militia companies like
the pottawatomie rifles led by john
brown jr his father while not a formal
member would ride along with them
whenever trouble seemed likely this is
what they were doing on may 23 1856
riding to lawrence after word came that
the city was being threatened by
pro-slavery forces but before they
arrived messenger met up with him and
shared the news that lawrence had been
sacked stores looted buildings burned
printing presses destroyed no one had
been hurt because the citizens of
lawrence had decided not to fight back
later that day more distressing news
came in washington senator charles
sumner of massachusetts a devout
abolitionist had been beaten very badly
inside the capitol building by
representative preston brooks of south
carolina for john brown this was the
last straw the way he saw it the south
had thrown down the gauntlet and he was
determined to pick it up he led a band
of men mostly consisting of his own sons
away from the rest of the militia and on
to potowatomi creek near where the brown
family lived there they went from cabin
to cabin dragging notable pro-slavery
men outside and hacking them to death
with swords the total of five men were
slain before brown's group but had
enough the pottawatomie massacre as it
became known touched off a full-scale
war in eastern kansas bands of free
soldiers and border ruffians rode around
the territory engaging each other in
skirmishes and fights that left men dead
on both sides houses were burned cat or
stolen neighbors turned on each other in
brutal sectarian violence reminiscent of
the european wars of religion 200 years
earlier it would take months for federal
troops to bring the region under control
by which time more than 200 people have
been killed meanwhile john brown escaped
from what the new york tribune was
calling bleeding kansas unscathed after
participating in several battles one of
which claimed the life of his son
frederick brown had become a national
figure as a result of the kansas
fighting and it wanted to parlay that
fame into what he now viewed as his
god-given mission to destroy slavery in
the united states
when john brown spoke to audiences in
northern cities proclaiming that god had
chosen him to lead a campaign to free
the slaves by any means necessary it was
viewed as being little on the extreme
side rhetoric wise but it was not
dismissed as being the ramblings of an
insane person as it probably would have
been if it done it today he certainly
never gave off any outward signs of
mental illness he never claimed to be
receiving visions or hearing voices from
god commanding him to act or that he had
any supernatural powers bestowed on him
by the deity what he had was a sincere
conviction that of all the people in
america he was the one best suited to
lead the campaign against the slave
power not with words but with action
regardless of how strong his faith was
it must have appeased his ego that so
many people in the north were listening
to him now over the course of the next
two years brown went on a public
speaking tour of the north recounting
his heroic deeds in the kansas conflict
notably leaving out any detail about the
pottawatomie massacre and soliciting
money to continue the struggle most of
his audience assumed that he meant
returning to kansas but secretly brown
had something much more grandiose in
mind brown believed that the slave
population was primed for revolting
against their white masters studying the
campaigns of two slaves turned general
spartacus and ancient rome and du salt
levature in haiti convinced him that he
could ignite a similar slave rebellion
in the american south at that point
there were four million enslaved people
in the country including large
populations of hundreds of thousands of
slaves in the deep south in some states
like south carolina there were more
slaves than there were free people white
or black brown thought that all that was
needed was a spark something for the
slaves to rally around as well as
weapons and then he could build an
unstoppable army of free blacks who
would sweep slavery out of every corner
of the country but where to get those
weapons from brown couldn't buy them
that would require vast sums of money
that he was unable to raise and he would
have drawn attention to what he was
doing after briefly entertaining a
scheme to manufacture pykes to issue to
the slaves he came to the conclusion
that the only one with a store of arms
large enough for his purposes was the
federal government the us army at this
point was small and mostly concentrated
in the west but the government
maintained armories large repositories
of stored guns in strategic locations so
that they'd have them in case of trouble
one of these store houses was the
federal arsenal at harpers ferry
virginia the small town of harpers ferry
occupied a strategic location in
virginia close to the maryland border it
sat at the junction of two large rivers
the shenandoah and the potomac which
made it a natural transportation hub it
had been a manufacturing couple decades
and its largest employer was the arsenal
which both manufactured and stored
rifles for the army there were estimated
to be around a hundred thousand guns
stored at harpers ferry in 1859 more
than enough for brown's revolution
brown's plan was to capture the arsenal
seize the weapons and put the word out
that the revolution was underway waiting
in the town for his army to appear to be
armed and trained no doubt brown
anticipated countless legions of
biblical proportions flocking to his
banner with himself placed at their head
at this point the old man's hair had
changed from black to white and he had
grown a large beard drawing comparison
to the prophet moses which probably
pleased him just as moses had led the
israelites to freedom so would john
brown
lead the slaves to freedom
brown's raiders as they came to be known
consisted of himself and 21 other men
he'd tried to recruit more including his
friend frederick douglass the most
famous black man in america but douglas
had declined declaring brown's plan
suicidal it is estimated that up to 80
people had advanced knowledge of brown's
attack including his primary financial
back as a group of influential northern
philanthropists and reformers called the
secret six there had even been a letter
sent to the secretary of war warning him
of brown's plans but the secretary
dismissed the letter as a hoax so when
brown and his troops rode into harpers
ferry at 11 pm on october 16 1859 they
took the sleepy town completely by
surprise they quickly captured the
arsenal overwhelming the single night
watchmen on duty cut the telegraph lines
and seized control of the bridges that
provided access to the town they took
hostages the most notable of which was
lewis washington great-grandnephew
george washington john brown carried
general washington sword around with him
during the raid as a talisman the first
part of his plan had gone off without a
hitch he had the town and the guns now
all he had to do was wait for the slave
rebellion to begin however there was one
glaring oversight in brown's plan that
seems obvious to anybody looking back on
it today he had no way to contact the
slaves directly to tell them what was
happening how were they supposed to know
to rise up and come to harper's ferry to
join his army when word did get out it
reached the white slave owning populous
first who promptly overreacted like all
slave masters as much as they looked
down upon their slaves they also feared
what would happen if they ever rose up
in rebellion against them militia
companies from both maryland and
virginia were assembled and sent to
harpers ferry these companies surrounded
the raiders preventing their escape but
were overall disorganized and not very
willing to expose themselves to danger
instead exchanging sporadic fire with
brown's men throughout the day on
october 17th many of them took it as an
excuse to get drunk hoping to get a
handle on the situation president
buchanan dispatched a company of u.s
marines from washington to seize back
the armory in command of the operation
was army colonel robert e lee a
decorated mexican war veteran who was
considered one of the country's best
soldiers lee's aide was lieutenant j.e.b
steward who had encountered john brown
before during the days of bleeding
kansas both would go on to become
celebrated generals during the civil war
at 6 30 a.m on october the 18th stewart
approached the fire engine house where
brown surviving raiders had taken refuge
under a white flag he spoke with brown
imploring him to surrender so that their
lives would be spared when brown refused
stewart signaled lee who sent in the
marines they broke down the door and
fought their way inside capturing brown
and the rest of his band it was all over
in a few minutes brown who had been
seriously wounded was carried out of the
engine house along with the rest of the
survivors the butcher's bill was high of
the 19 men who had participated in the
harper's ferry raid ten had been killed
or mortally wounded and seven captured
four town residents including the mayor
had also been killed as well as a marine
during the final assault
under other circumstances brown's raid
might have been a footnote in history
the man himself quickly dismissed is
just another crackpot but as john
brown's trial played out during the last
week of october 1859 he became a cause
celeb in the north and the devil
incarnate in the south the trial itself
was largely for show as there was little
doubt about brown's guilt or what the
punishment for his crimes was to be it
was the first trial in america covered
nationwide as it happened thanks to the
telegraph and it became a circus with
the governor of virginia surrounding the
courthouse with an army of militia units
because he was convinced a diabolical
northern plot was at hand to set round
free there wasn't but that didn't stop
them from putting a cannon on the
courthouse steps brown himself didn't
want to be rescued he recognized the
propaganda value his death would bring
to his cause and spurned all efforts
made on his behalf to save his life he
accepted every interview request and
received and wrote many letters during
his imprisonment impressing many both
north and south was eloquence bravery
and the strength of his convictions that
didn't stop southern newspapers from
paying for his blood however along with
all the other abolitionists that dared
try to deprive them of their rightful
property in the north meanwhile brown
was seen as a martyr someone who had
perhaps gone a little too far in the
name of a good cause it also caused many
to question whether violence was an
acceptable price to pay for the
abolition of slavery including many who
had been pacifists before the raid brown
himself was certainly convinced of the
righteousness of his cause right to the
end he gave no last speech before being
hanged on december the 2nd but he passed
a note to his jailer that said in part i
john brown i'm now quite certain that
the crimes of this guilty land will
never be purged away but with blood it
turned out to be a prophetic final
missive a year after his execution the
southern states reacted to the election
of abraham lincoln as president by
trying to leave the union and form their
own country the confederacy triggering
the american civil war between six
hundred thousand and eight hundred
thousand people would die in that
conflict including almost a fifth of
southern men in the ages of 18 to 43. in
the end the south lost and they were
dragged back into the country by force
which now included the 13th amendment to
the constitution permanently abolishing
slavery many people today continued to
debate john brown's legacy while his
raid did not lead directly to the civil
war it certainly contributed to it as it
provided further proof of nefarious
intentions to two parts of the country
that didn't know how to communicate with
each other anymore while there probably
still would have been civil war even
without john brown's actions it might
not have started when it did or taken
the form that it did and it might not
have ended with the abolition of slavery
the way that it did there are some
historians who believe that his
intentions were to set the north and
south against each other all along
knowing that his raid would fail and the
only way to free the slaves was with a
northern army defeating the south in
battle the other thing people question
is whether john brown's actions were
justified whether they were a good thing
his cause was objectively a righteous
one certainly but his decision to use
violence in order to advance a political
aim arguably makes him america's first
domestic terrorist had he been born in
the 20th century what cause mighty have
championed instead of slavery and would
he have seen violence as an acceptable
solution to those problems too there's
no way to know for sure in any case it's
probably better to take the historian's
view that there are no heroes and
villains when telling the story of the
past only historical events and their
impact on future ones and whatever
anyone says about john brown he
certainly fills both those categories
perfectly well
[Music]